welcome back to Long crime daily
everybody after just a couple of hours
of deliberation the jury in the Civil
Trial between Terry Sanderson and
Gwyneth Paltrow reached a decision the
jury was tasked with deciding who was at
fault for a 2016 Collision on a Utah ski
slope
was Gwyneth Paltrow at fault no
was Gwyneth Paltrow's fault a cause of
Terry sanderson's harm
oh
no there's just no response there
was Terry sand
Ro's
did um did Terry sanderson's fault cause
Gwyneth Paltrow's harm yes
comparative fault
what percent of the fault do you assign
to Terry Sanderson
100 percent
one of the jurors involved in that
decision spoke exclusively with Good
Morning America about what part of the
testimony sealed the deal
expert in many different ways
I think the fact that Dr sure could
speak to the den settings and he
specifically studied snow science that
she had a stronger opinion
and the drama didn't end with the
verdict as she was leaving the courtroom
Gwyneth Paltrow leaned down and said
something to Terry Sanderson outside
Sanderson confirmed that she had leaned
down and wished him all the best which
he said was a very nice thing for her to
do and he appreciated it Sanderson
claimed that Paltrow ran into him on the
ski slope leaving him with broken ribs
and even brain damage but the jury
disagreed in a statement put out
Thursday night Paltrow said quote I felt
that acquiescing to a false claim
compromised my Integrity I am pleased
with the outcome and I appreciate all
the hard work of Judge Holmberg and the
jury and thank them for their
thoughtfulness in handling this case now
there's been no word on whether Terry
Sanderson will file an appeal of the
verdict but we asked a personal injury
defense attorney in Utah if she saw any
legal errors in the case
you know it's a lot of evidence has come
in I think judge Holmberg candidly is
probably the shining star of this entire
trial he's very well respected within
Utah I think he's done a very good job
of marshaling the evidence being fair to
both sides I have had the opportunity to
watch a lot of it as most people have
and I think his rulings were fair to
both sides I think they were based in
the law which is always a great thing
for a judge to do and so at this point I
don't see based on the trial testimony
itself that there are any appellate
issues
Brian Quick verdict unanimous vote
Sanderson 100 liable were you shocked in
any of this not at the ultimate end of
it all but I was shocked to some degree
as to the absolute assurities that these
jurors had a hundred percent liable I
thought they would have maybe felt some
sympathy towards Sanderson and maybe
done a 90-10 I thought Gwyneth Paltrow
and her attorneys were far superior in
the Martian the evidence I think they
had stronger facts and I do think that
Dr sure was the star witness in this all
it's one thing to say that you are a
biomechanical expert it's another thing
to say you're a biomechanical expert
when it comes to skiing and so I I think
that the jury got it right I was just
surprised that it was really a hundred
percent to zero and unanimous I thought
there might have been a little bit
longer or maybe even a small percentage
going towards Anderson Well Terry some
people thought that Paltrow should have
just settled this not even taken this to
court why do you think it was important
for her to defend herself Oh I thought
it was very important and this is why
Jesse you cannot just acquiesce to these
types of claims and I think she did the
right thing in making sure she defended
herself I tried multiple cases defending
the city of New York personal injury
cases and people line up when they see
Deep Pockets and if you start paying
settlements because it's a nuisance then
you will have multiple more people
coming to try to get claims that don't
have any Merit it took a lot for her to
sit there you heard her attorney say she
had to take the time and the effort she
was there every day Sanderson wasn't
even there every day so I applaud her
and it's a matter of principle it's also
a matter of money and it's the right
thing to do so kudos to her for doing
that yeah while she not only won in the
court of law maybe she also wore one in
the court of public opinion this is a
big victory for Gwyneth Paltrow and we
will see what happens next with a
potential appeal